I wanted to ask you about what you bring
to the table in a long-term relationship
or a
marriage me what do I bring to the table
everybody everybody Harley if you want
to start because you just popped in fire
away someone else can start okay Liz do
you want to
go um well like I said earlier I'm 23 um
and I don't really have my [__] figured
out as much as like a grown adult would
so I don't know I think I'm a generally
good person person I think I'm talented
and passionate um and open-minded I can
really see stuff from both sides and
um do think want from a
woman what do you think want from a
woman
list
uh I'll come back to you in a minute
Jasmine y that's a good question is such
an autistic question it because it
depends on man why is it an autic
question I'm asking you what you bring
to the table in a longterm well then you
have to give the [__] dumb I'm nice
I'm loyal like there's just nothing you
could really like oh what I have huge
tits like what the [__] do you say well
aside from the TNA obviously yeah I have
great cooking skills like what is not
stupid answer to that I just want to
know well didn't you say that you don't
cook jasmine I don't so I'm saying but
like that would be a great answer
according to you or like what would be
I'm sweet I'm l i listen I'm attentive
like it's just like so you don't have an
answer then I felt silly answering it
yeah it's a silly question it's like
yeah low I
mean question what do you bring to the
table in a relationship to a
woman the ability to provide protect
offer paternity D it's pretty simple
okay stuff right yeah offer like that's
take care of the house I pay the bills
protect weird response then sure in this
space it not weird question what weird
in what way is it weird to be able to
provide children for the woman that I
want to be
with it's fine I'm just saying like or
being able to be a masculine man who can
raise them my opinion and in
lizz's these aren't questions that we
would even ask and if I went to if I was
on a date and I was like what can you
provide the ability to protect provide
and offer paternity I would like text my
friends like okay you know I mean you
may not ask it but I mean you're
assessing them for that I don't think
that anybody would out like I wouldn't
say these to a person I'm trying to I
agree that's why it's a weird question
to ask on this podcast but okay no but
it's not because we're not nobody's
trying to date you and I think we're
trying to have open conversations about
what men generally find attractive and
want from women and what women find
generally attractive and want from men
so sitting here saying the questions are
stupid is kind of [__] dumb it's like
but you're it's like you're a setup it's
like yeah and there's no answer that
doesn't sound in my opinion ridiculous
and so and lizz's opinion too so we're
just at a difference of opinion because
women in here obviously find the
question silly you don't but it's a
genuine question right I mean you have
to you have to know like women are all
about their value and I know my worth
and their value so what I'm asking is
you know what is it that you bring to
the table in a long-term relationship or
a marriage with a man right that's you
know like it's a genuine question s like
I'm nice okay sure I'm nice I'm smart
you're not nice I am nice not can tell
that's subjective yeah that's subjective
I'm not nice to you guys but I'm i't
seen you
nice to anybody that you've talked to on
anyast any of the men I've been with
they would say I'm nice to them um so it
just depends I also don't find you know
you guys to be nice but I'm sure you're
nice to the women that you are around so
this is one it's a super subjective
question I'm intelligent I can have good
conversations I'm very supportive like I
like we could talk about it sounds like
we're in like yeah loyal it sounds like
we're doing like job interview okay so
what do you ladies sorry Harley let's go
let's go um I would say like uh like I
have a good work ethic and I feel like
that's something that um like I'm not
speaking for like anybody else but uh
like women my age just seem to like um
lack that or at least I see a lack of
that like I'm a bartender and a waitress
in like downtown Nashville and it's
pretty busy down there and just like in
my job alone and like other jobs that
I've had like girls my age don't have
nearly like work I'm 20 I just turned 25
okay so work E I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out